these two Kenyan ladies were best
friends from neighboring villages but
they'd stop seeing each other literally
for ten years because both had gone
blind from a curable condition called
cataract they hadn't been aware they've
been sat together for over an hour when
we offered them surgery at the nearest
hospital
mama Jane on the right told me her
biggest fear was that she would poison
her grandson whom she'd never seen
because she couldn't see what she was
cooking for him her arms were covered in
burns from cooking on a charcoal stove
and she despaired that she was robbing
her six-year-old grandson of his
childhood because he was effectively her
eyes the effect of her blindness was
going through the generations he wasn't
able to go to school or break the cycle
of poverty all of this despite
cost-effective solutions existing
cataract surgery can be done in under 10
minutes for just $100 for and every five
people who were blind don't need to be
curative or preventive treatments
already exist
fortunately for Mama Jane and her friend
a donor had provided treatment so that
we could take them to the nearest
hospital three hours away but in that
very same clinic I met Theresa a shy
young woman who couldn't look me in the
eyes not because she couldn't see but
the appearance of the growths on her
eyes called pterygium meant she'd lost
her confidence and wither her place in
their community
she had no prospects for marriage or
children and had been completely
ostracized I knew how to treat her
condition it was pretty straightforward
but we had strict instructions that the
funds we had were for people with
cataract what was I supposed to do
ignore her my wife and I managed to
raise the funds to cover her treatment
but situations like Teresa were common
every day where people had the wrong
diseases and buy the wrong diseases
I mean conditions for which funding
hadn't been earmarked earmarking may
seem like smart business or smart plants
be on paper
but it doesn't make any sense when
you're looking the person in the eye yet
this is how we deliver health care to
millions of people the world over I've
been thinking about this problem for a
very long time
things happen to me at the age of 12
that completely transformed my life my
teachers insisted that I would go for an
eye test I resisted it for as many years
as I could because as the only brown boy
in the school I already felt like a
chocolate chip in rice pudding and the
idea of looking more different was not
particularly appealing is he I've
associated an eye test with wearing
glasses and looking different not with
seeing differently when eventually I was
persuaded to go the optometrist fitted
me with the trial lenses and was shocked
at just how poor my sight was he sent me
outside to report what I could see I
remember looking up and seeing trees had
leaves on them I had never known this
later that week for the first time I saw
stars in the night sky it's breathtaking
in fact the entire trajectory of my life
changed I went from a failing child at
school who's constantly told I was lazy
and not paying attention to suddenly
being a child with opportunity and
potential but I soon realized that this
opportunity was not Universal that same
summer in Egypt the home where my
parents originally from I was with
children that looked a lot more like me
but couldn't have been more different
what separated us was opportunity how is
it that I had this life and they had
theirs it still makes no sense to me
how is it weave in a world where glasses
that completely changed my life have
been around for seven hundred years yet
two and a half billion people still
can't access them this deep sense of
injustice drove me to become a doctor
eventually an eye surgeon and in 2012 my
wife and I packed our bags and moved to
Kenya to try and give something back
we started by setting up a hundred eye
clinics across the Great Rift Valley
where we met people like Mama Jane and
Teresa we founded a new organization
called peak vision a social and social
enterprise where we build smartphone
technology that makes it possible
for people in the community to find
people in their homes the most
vulnerable groups who are being missed
created new tools that made it easier to
diagnose them and connect them to
services inspired by the challenges I'd
had as a child we equip teachers 25 of
them with smartphones to screen children
in schools our first program resulted in
21,000 children being screened in just
nine days that same program was
replicated to reach 200,000 children
covering the entire district soon we
were able to repeat this in six new
programs in different countries but now
I was faced with the very same problems
I had with Teresa of earmarked funds but
now as an organization people wanted to
fund specific projects or particular
diseases or subsets of the population
but it didn't make sense because what we
needed to do was build an incredible
team who could create the systems that
would change the lives of millions of
people whatever their needs were but it
didn't work that way soon we were able
to align ourselves with partners who
understood because I understand the
challenge ultimately you need to trust
where your money's going and that trust
usually manifests through the
requirement to create detailed plans
lots of paperwork but what happens if
the dynamic needs of people don't fit
with the plan that you created and your
funding is dependent on delivering the
plan you end up with a choice you serve
the plan Thunder or do you serve the
need this is not a choice we should have
to make because ultimately we can only
serve one master a measure of our
humanity is how we serve the most
vulnerable amongst us currently the
system is not working and too many
people are being left behind we've been
fortunate to find incredible supporters
and partners which led to a new program
in Botswana in which every single school
child has been screened and treated by
the 8th by the end of 2021 meaning an
entire generation of children will have
the opportunity that good vision affords
but this took years of work it took
multiple feasibility studies engaging
different partners and stakeholders
business cases economic analyses to
persuade the government to eventually
come on board but they're now leading
and funding this in their own national
budget but we did not have the resources
to do this our visionary funders and
partners came alongside us and the key
ingredients were we were aligned on
mission on the why we were doing it we
agreed on the outcome what had to be
done but critically they were flexible
and gave us autonomy to work out how we
got there giving us the space to be
creative ambitious and take risk what if
all healthcare looked like this what
would it mean for all of social the
social causes were trying to solve
business knows this by taking a
long-term ambitious view and giving
people the autonomy to be creative to
solve our world's biggest challenges
we've disrupted entire industries look
at Amazon Google surely we need the same
level of ambition if we're going to
serve the most vulnerable in our
societies as a planet we've set a target
to sustainable development goals yet
we're spending less than half the amount
on tackling the global goals than we are
on conflict resolution which may slea
rises from the very inequalities we're
not serving it's time for change it's
not just common sense as well it makes
business sense our work in Botswana
showed for a modest investment the
economy would gain 1.3 billion dollars
over the lifetime of her children that
was a hundred and fifty times return on
investment but part of the problem is
that values generated in the future but
we need the money now to deliver it
turns out this is not a new problem
banks have been solving it for centuries
simply put it's called financing if you
want to buy a house but you can't afford
to pay for it upfront the bank finances
you see can realize that future value
now in other words you can live in the
house straight away but what if you
couldn't what if you had to wait till
you've raised all of the money to move
into the house and you were kept
homeless whilst trying to save the money
to get there in the first place you'd
end up in an impossible cycle never able
to get there yeah that's this very same
bind we've put on
selves inspired by the change in
Botswana and by the visionary support of
our funders and partners we've come
together to world leading banks
for-profit and private not-for-profit
organizations foundations and
philanthropists to launch the vision
catalyst fund a fund which will have
trust built in by design it will make
funding available now to the
organizations that can serve the need of
the most vulnerable it will ensure that
those organizations can work together in
partnership rather than competing for
limited funds serving the priority needs
of an entire population whatever they
are so that ultimately the individuals
affected can receive the care that they
deserve and as we've shown it doesn't
make just a health and social difference
it creates huge economic benefit this
benefit in itself will create
sustainability to perpetuate a virtuous
catalytic cycle of improvement and
change because when we do this the
individual needs of people I myself can
be met and this Coalition has come
together this year to make a commitment
with 53 Heads of Government we have now
committed to take action towards
achieving access to quality I care for
all we've had incredible commitments of
200 million pairs of glasses to the fund
and millions of dollars so that the
dynamic and individual needs of people
like my own issues that I had as a child
like Teresa who just required simple
surgery can be met for Teresa it meant
her place back in society now with her
own family and children and for Mama
Jane it wasn't just restoring her sight
it meant the opportunity to restore hope
to restore joy and to restore dignity
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]